hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast simultaneous single-cell
visualization RNA and protein presented
by sarah becker Catania PhD we are
excited to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by laberd's and
sponsored by Hugh bioscience Affymetrix
key bioscience metrics technologies
enable multiplex and simultaneous
analysis of biological systems at the
shell protein and gene level
facilitating the rapid translation of
benchtop research into clinical and
routine use for human health and
wellness at metrics part of thermo
Fisher Scientific provides leadership
and supports partnering with customers
in pharmaceutical diagnostic and
biotechnology companies and leading
academic government and nonprofit
research institutes in a quest to use
biology for a better world to learn more
visit WWE bioscience calm I am jr.
Oracle a Brutes and I'll be your
moderator for today's event
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green -
and a button located in the lower left
of the presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
and finally if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of the presentation window
or use the Q&A button to let us know
that you're having a problem thank you
now I'd like to introduce dr. Sarah
Becker catania dr. Becker Catania is an
associate director in R&D at E
bioscience where she leads a team
dedicated to the development of
immunology focused reagents for flow
cytometry and microscopy applications
she received a PhD in experimental
pathology at the University of
California
Angeles studying the genotype and
phenotype correlations of a rare
neurodegenerative disorder ataxia
telangiectasia dr. Becker Catania did
her postdoctoral training as a Giannini
Foundation fellow at the UCLA
neuropsychiatric Institute mental
retardation Research Center
studying the selected specification of
neural stem cells along girl and glial
lineages following her postdoc training
she held a joint appointment as a
research assistant professor at the
University of Illinois Chicago and the
Heinz VA hospital and was a recipient of
an Illinois regenerative medicine
institute stem-cell grant for her work
with neural stem cells and models of
multiple sclerosis please join me in
welcoming dr. Sarah Becker catania I
will now turn the presentation over to
her Thank You Judy and lab roots for the
opportunity to speak today about the
development of a new assay that allows
us to look at visualizing RNA and
protein in single cells cellular
heterogeneity is present in any
biological sample and whether it be at
the level of gene expression protein or
differences in post translational
modifications most of our understanding
of gene and protein expression has been
from methods that really look at entire
populations and give an average result
well this is really useful and it's been
a foundation for science leading up to
this point the last few years
scientific methodology has really
advanced and it's our advanced our
ability as researchers to understand the
role and the contribution of single
cells over the last five years we've
seen an increase in publications and
embracing the single-cell approach to
all types of models in biology and it
really started out in 2013 in Nature
Methods as they published the method of
the year which was single-cell
sequencing and as we can see over
publications in different areas of
biology a market increase in the number
of publications that look at single cell
biology in an effort to really
understand the role of the rare
so these are sometimes masked in studies
where we've looked at population
averages so this was a real limitation
in our R&D department here in product
development at a bioscience we already
utilize a lot of techniques that look at
single cell biology we use flow
cytometry we use in situ hybridization
amino Saito chemistry and
immunohistochemistry
on a daily basis but a problem that we
came across was really looking at
understanding the role of an mRNA or an
RNA species in the same cell as protein
and so when we looked and using RNAi ish
and we currently have a assay that does
this this is the view RNA cell assay we
can easily detect messenger RNA in the
figure on the left and we can detect
protein using antibody based methods
like immuno Saito chemistry as shown in
the center image but when we try to
combine these two assays we did not get
the results on the right which would
have been emerged of the two
methodologies and the reason for that is
the two protocols that are used for
immuno Saito chemistry and in situ
hybridization are very incompatible so
it either results in a destruction of
the RNA or a destruction of the antigen
that the antibody recognizes so the
challenge was really finding a method of
protocol and reagents that would allow
us to do both in the same cell in the
same cell cultured in a dish so what I'm
going to show you in the next slides was
the development of that assay and a
protocol in the solutions to really look
at message and protein in the same cell
and this assay is what we call the view
RNA cell plus si so it's a novel assay
uses multiplex fluorescence to detect
protein and RNA and single cells and
this group of images really shows the
breadth of the assay and the differ
types of cells that has been used to
look at different proteins and RNA
everything from cervical adenocarcinoma
cells to virally infected epithelial
cells shown at the top right as well as
models of circulating tumor cells
neurons and glia and epithelial cells so
all of the different types of cells that
a researcher might encounter in a
typical look into their model of
interest the applications of the assay
are far-reaching it allows us to analyze
sample heterogeneity we're interested in
looking at mixed populations whether it
be looking at one rare cell within a
mixed population or even understanding
the differences between what we think is
a homogeneous population for example a
cell line and I'll show some data later
in the presentation that really will
make you think twice about what we
accept as a cell line and accepting that
we think that it's homogeneous when
perhaps it's not really that homogeneous
it allows you to correlate RNA and
protein kinetics within the same cell
we've done some studies looking at
non-coding RNAs including micro RNA and
long non-coding RNA and cellular subsets
we've analyzed messenger RNA expression
levels when there isn't an antibody
available which commonly happens it
allows us to track and visualize viral
RNA and there is the potential for
high-throughput compound screening if
the assay is adapted to a platform
that's used in those types of
applications for imaging if we look at
the workflow of the assay this is an
overview so on the left hand side sample
preparation and antibody staining is the
first step in the protocol so samples
can either be grown in 96-well plates or
in chamber slides or on cover slips in
24 weld plates or they can be suspension
cells that have been Saito spun onto
slides then at this point the sample is
fixed and permeable eyes in a single
step antibody staining is done and
sometimes secondary standing in the
antibody if that's the choice that the
researcher chooses and I'll go into more
detail on this in slides coming and then
the next step is really detecting the
RNA of interest so we do this using
specific probe sets designed for the RNA
of interest and they can either be in
three different types and the type of
the probe set really determines how it
will be detected for microscopy so a
type one probe set will use an amplifier
and a preamplifier and label probe that
is a type one label problem this is
detected in the alexa fluor 546 channel
on the microscope whereas a type 4 is
corresponds to an Alexa 488 detection
and a type 6 corresponds to an alexa
fluor 647 Laura 4 so these are
sequential hybridizations where we can
look at multiple rnas within the same
cell as well as antibodies and then the
readout the detection portion of the
assay is done using either a standard
epi fluorescent microscope or a high
content imager in looking at more depths
at the experimental workflow it's really
broken down into two days in this case
step one on day one this portion of the
protocol here looks at detection of the
protein of interest where it's using
antibody mediated basically immune aside
a chemistry to detect the antibody then
a fixation step is done and then the
assay proceeds into hybridization to
look at the target RNA a hold and wash
buffer overnight and then on day 2 this
is an amplification of the detection of
the RNA signal so the total assay time
on day 1 is 6 to 8 hours and on day 2 is
4 to 5 hours and this doesn't
include imaging time and the hands-on
time is two-three hours on day one or
one to two hours on day two in looking
at more depth at the protein detection
strategy there are a couple different
ways to think about performing the assay
and there's a lot of flexibility built
into the assay so one can use a direct
protocol and indirect I mean that the
antibody that you're choosing to use to
detect your antigen of interest or your
protein of interest in the assay can be
directly conjugated to a fluorophore
this is a nice way to go because the
protocol is faster you don't have to use
a secondary antibody or a secondary
antibody with a streptavidin as in the
two step and three step protocols shown
below
the beauty of the direct protocol is
really the ease of use if you want to
look at multiple antigens and they're
both for instance a mouse IgG one
isotype it becomes very difficult to do
a two step protocol where you're using
an anti Mouse secondary because you'll
have cross reaction between the two
primary antibodies so if you're using a
direct protocol it's very easy to use
one anybody that's labeled with an Alexa
488 for example and another one that's
labeled with an Alexa for 647 but it
doesn't it doesn't mean that that's
always the best way that you should do
it or the only way that you can do it
and there's a lot of antigens that may
be expressed at very low levels which
require a two or a three step protocol
to really amplify the signal and to
really be able to detect the antigen of
interest in which case a two step or a
three step protocol is advantageous
simply because it allows you this
amplification of that signal of antigen
and it either either method is
applicable in this assay there's no
limitation to that it's just whichever
is at is the right approach for your
antigen of interest and this really
depends on the level of expression of
that antigen
so in choosing the antibody there are
some criteria that are very important so
the first step is really to identify
which antigen or antigens are of
interest to you and to identify
candidate antibodies that will work in
the assay so the criteria for the
antibodies is that they typically
perform well in an immuno static
chemistry as a say-so not these aren't
necessarily anybody's that work for
immunohistochemistry or formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded you know tissue those
may be different anybody's but these are
typically antibodies that work for cells
that are grown and fixed in a dish the
antibodies that tend to perform very
well in this assay or anybody's that
perform well under formaldehyde fixation
and criminalization conditions
antibodies that are used following
acetone fixation or methanol fixation
don't tend to work very well with this
protocol that's been designed and that's
just one limitation of the protocol most
of the antibodies that are available for
immuno Saito chemistry
tend to fit into the formaldehyde
fixation and permeabilization group so
there is a lot of flexibility and a lot
of different specificities that can be
performed with this assay so you can
either use a purified or a fluorophore
conjugated as I spoke about in the last
slide and that really depends on whether
or not you have a floor for a conjugated
antibody to the specificity that you're
interested in and also whether you think
that that antigen has expressed at low
levels and may need the amplified signal
that you would get from using a
secondary antibody or a secondary by
automated antibody with for example a
streptavidin conjugated to a fluorophore
the next step is really to test the
performance of the antibody on your
cells using the view RNA self of sticks
and primulas ation buffer set so we sell
just a the buffer set alone and this is
specifically for the purpose of testing
your antibodies to make sure they can
perform well in the assay there's
limited value in looking doing the whole
say if the antibodies that you're using
don't perform well this also allows you
to tighter your primary and secondary on
advice which we recommend anytime you're
running it running an assay where you're
you're looking at maybe a different cell
type and you haven't run that particular
anybody before you should always tighter
the primary and secondary antibodies and
decide if you're going to use for for
conjugated anybody's the next step is
then to perform the the whole assay with
the RNA detection and for validated
antibodies we have a list of clones and
flora for conjugated antibodies that
have already been validated in the past
day and this can be found on our website
at the address below so as we look past
now the detection of protein and we look
at the detection of RNA the RNA
detection is done using a branch DNA
amplification and this is really the
basis for the view RNA cell assay that
we currently sell that just allows you
to look at RNA but in this particular
assay what we have is we have detection
of RNA using a target probe mix so
basically these are probes that are
designed to specifically to the target
RNA of interest and it requires a paired
set of these to bind to the target RNA
and then with each sequential addition
first preamplifier is added which binds
to the extender region of the target
probe and forms the trunk of this
structure that will be formed that will
allow you to detect the RNA the next
step was the addition of the amplifier
and the amplifier really the branches
that bind to this preamplifier and the
last step is the addition of the label
probe and the label probe binds to the
amplifier and from each set of target
probes two of these probes you can have
the addition of 400 labeled probes onto
this tree structure which really allows
you the amplification to see the RNA
within
so the target probe sets are designed to
be highly specific and sensitive so
first you would need to determine your
RNA of interest you need to have an
accession number for that and then
decide which probe type you would like
for it to be so probe type as I said
before refers to the type of detection
channel that you would like to see your
RNA and a type 1 is similar to a trizzie
or an Alexa 5:46 type 4 is similar to an
Alexa 48 and a type 6 is an Alexa 647 so
then the Affymetrix biometrics
information team identifies regions
within the RNA that you're interested in
that would give the highest specificity
over a range of about a thousand
nucleotides and designs a probe set
composed of about twenty all ago pairs
that are highly specific for your RNA of
interest so the probes are manufactured
some of them are already commercially
available these are the same probes that
are used for the view cell assay and if
it's required that they be synthesized
it takes less than a week to get the
probes so the next thing I want to do is
show you some of the specificity data
from these probes so if we look at the
specificity of the assay we know that it
requires the binding of both of those
probes a pair a probe pair set to really
form the tree structure so in this case
what we've done is we've looked at an
mRNA gap th which is a typically a
housekeeping gene is used a lot for that
purpose and what we've done here is we
have taken the left portion left probe
and the right probe and we've hybridized
them alone and you can see in the two
images on the left and in the center
that there is no corresponding signal of
RNA
so the RNA signal here would be white
and you can see the only thing you see
are the nuclei of the cells which are
stained blue for Daffy and then on the
right-hand side the right-hand image
where you see the white punctate dots
each dot corresponds to an individual
mRNA gap th mRNA and the image on the
right is done under standard conditions
where we've used paired probes the left
and the right probe together to yield a
signal and then we followed with the
addition of the preamplifier the
amplifier and the labeled probe to
really build up that tree structure
which really allows us to detect the the
single RNA species so these images were
taken all at the same exposure time so
they're matched exposures so we can
really truly evaluate the amount of
signal between each of these different
conditions in this case the second
example of specificity we've gone ahead
and on the left-hand side we emitted
adding the the probe so this is a no
probe control and you can see that when
you omit that probe you do not have
nonspecific binding of the preamplifier
amplifier or label probe the tree cannot
form without and bind to the cells
without the addition of the probe this
image in the center is the DEP B control
and dat B is just an e.coli gene and so
it should not be expressed these are
human HeLa cells and so there should not
be any expression of death the mRNA in
the cells and we can see that there is
no signal present the only thing we see
are the nuclei of the cells and then on
the right hand image we see the gap
being positive control and these has
just got the H staining here in the
cells this is showing individual mRNA
and this is the expected signal on the
right hand side and again these images
were all taken at the same exposure time
and shows really that there is no
nonspecific binding of the preamplifier
amplifier label probe components of the
without actual binding of that initial
probe pair in this case what we're doing
here is we're looking at a comparison of
the view RNA cell assay which is the
assay that's currently sold by
Affymetrix
which allows you to look at RNA and then
a comparison to results of the view RNA
cell plus a C which allows you to look
at RNA and protein so these cells are
HeLa cells the probe set is designed to
be 2 which is the gene that codes for
the mRNA that codes for the her2 protein
which is important in breast cancer and
what we're looking at in the two images
are probe sets designed to either exons
2 through 9 in red and this is a type 1
alexa fluor 546 probe set and a second
probe set which is a 488 probe set of
type 4 and this is designed to exon 10
through 20 and the reason we did this
was to look at paired red and green dots
so seemingly a paired red and green dot
would indicate a single mRNA where we
have tree structures formed on the 5
prime end of the mRNA and also on the 3
prime end of the RNA and it's very
difficult to look at these images
overlapped to see the two signals but if
we look I'll try to point to this for
example here we look up here we can see
two dots up here at corresponding to two
dots up here and these actually are
paired dots where we see the single mRNA
species and what we did was we went
ahead and quantitated the amount of type
1 and type 4 dots that we see between
the two assays and when we counted 6
cells
if we look at the average number of dots
per cell and the reason why we can
quantitate it this way is because the
Erb B 2 message is expressed at very low
levels in these cells so it allows us to
see individual dots and count them if we
look at the amount of expression an
average number of dots per cell in the
view standard s a type 1 AZ which is the
pink box and we look at the red bar next
to it the red bar is the view plus si we
see that the average number of type 1
and type 4 dots isn't significantly
different between the two assays if we
look at type 4 in green the light green
is the view cell assay and the darker
green is the view plus si it's not a
significant difference between the
number of dots that are detected between
the two assays
showing that there's a nice correlation
between results of the two essays this
is a actual comparison looking at a
housekeeping gene and they said b2
housekeeping genes beta-actin and PPI B
and both of these are the beta-actin
type 1 is in red and the ppi B type six
is in white and I have an inset box in
each image showing the PPI B expression
singly just imaging that channel alone
so that you can see it because sometimes
it's hard to detect the white on top of
the red signal so if we look at the cell
plus si which is shown in the top left
image we can see detection of beta-actin
mRNA in red and PPI B and white those
are the individual dots and then the
nuclei are counter stained with daffy in
blue and the top right image is the view
RNA cell assay and we see similar
expression of detection of beta-actin
type 1 and PPI B we can see in the inset
box is expressed in white so we have a
little bit more sensitive
detection of PPI b-type 6 and white with
the view cell plus assay and then if we
were to go ahead and look at the actual
image of the view cell as they merged
with the protein in this case we looked
at expression of alpha tubulin using
antibody directly conjugated to Alexa
488 and that's shown in the image on the
bottom left showing expression of
tubulin and green and beta-actin and red
and PPI B and white along with daffy
counterstain nuclei if we compare the
expression of protein between the view
plus assay and just standard immuno
Saito chemistry we see there's a very
nice correlation between the two the top
row of images is the view RNA cellquest
assay looking at three different
specificities golden protein Cox 4 and
ki-67 the bottom three images the row of
images is standard immuno site of
chemistry just using antibody and in
this case all of these were done
these are paired reagents so using an
antibody two golden efore 660 which is
similar to an Alexa 647 and this is
imaged in green here and we see very
nice expression between the view and RNA
cell plus si and standard immunise
Atacama stry these are the left top and
the left bottom images and we're looking
at the green signal which is the golden
protein which localizes to the Golgi
apparatus and you can see the nice
localization in the cells the Center
images are Cox for alexa fluor 488 is
the antibody that was used and this is a
mitochondrial protein and this is
expressed throughout the cell cytoplasm
and we can see in the immunity idol
chemistry assay the signal is just a
little bit brighter so sometimes in the
the cell plus assay to combine to assay
you do get a little diminishment of
signal of particular proteins and this
is highly protein specific so and it
varies most of the time we don't really
do
hittin the signal and this is still
quite useable to detect [ __ ] for a
protein but I pointed out because
there's there can be some differences
when you're combining two assays one for
looking at protein and one for looking
at RNA that you may not get exactly the
same performance as you would with a
immuno site of chemistry where you're
just looking at protein levels the last
two images on the right are looking at
ki 67 so ki 67 is a protein that's
involved and is expressed in actively
cycling cells and is expressed in the
nucleus and it's shown in white here and
it often appears that this punctate
white staining in the nucleus and we can
see that there's very nice concordance
of signal between the two assays so that
this is using a directly conjugated
protein
sorry antibody 2 and Alexa 64 660 which
is similar to an Alexa 647 floor and
that's shown in white next we looked at
the ability the assay to assess a
heterogeneous population of cells that
was in suspension so these were Mouse
splenocytes and they were treated as a
Saito spin preparation so the cells were
isolated and they were spun down onto
slides and the assay was performed on
slides so what we were looking at was a
population a mixed population and we're
looking for the expression of cd4 so cd4
is expressed on lymphocytes and we can
see in the left hand image expression of
cd4 mRNA and white and these are the
punctate pots indicating single copies
of city for mRNA and in the center image
we see cells that are staining pink very
lightly so this is surface expression of
cd4 since lymphocytes have very limited
cytoplasm the expression of cd4 or any
surface marker and a lymphocyte when you
look at it by cytosin often looks like
it's expressed right on the nucleus
because the cytoplasm is a scant and in
the merged image on the right we see
that the cells only the cells expressing
cd4 mRNA are look red or pink and
indicating a nice correlation between
the city for mRNA and the cd4 protein
and you see that cells that are other
types of cells maybe their cd8 positive
maybe their macrophage they don't
express the cd4 protein in the mixed
population we wanted to look at some
different models but researchers you
know typically used for their studies so
one of the ones that we picked was a
mile glass differentiation model and
this is using a mouse C 2 C 12 cell so
undifferentiated these cells if they're
put into differentiation conditions will
give rise to muscle cells so they're
often used to study myogenesis or
metabolism or muscle biology and they're
actively kept under high serum
conditions which left them proliferate
in culture and then when the experiment
is done
they're plated onto coverslips and the
serum is removed and they're put into a
low serum condition and this causes the
C 2 C 12 cells to differentiate and
four-mile tubules and they do this by up
regulating mile Jenin so when we look at
the assay performance in this population
here we're looking at differentiation of
mile s over five days so the top row of
images shows day zero day three and day
five and this is looking at
proliferation so to look at
proliferation we used an antibody to
ki-67 which marked proliferating cells
and this is a directly conjugated
antibody to e4 660 and it's shown here
in pink it's pink because it's the
signal is actually red and its
colloquialism with the cell nucleus
which is stained with daffy which is
blue so when there's co-localization
between the two it appears pink and the
image so we can see that the number of
pink cells is decreasing as we move from
day 0 to day 5 as the rim cells really
start to differentiate they stop
dividing and start differentiating
we also see that the amount of Myo Jenin
which is shown as white dots increases
in cells as we move from day 0 to day 5
indicating that these cells are up
regulating mile genin are starting to
differentiate if we look at the
differentiation markers on the bottom
row of images from day 0 to day 5 we see
that the amount of my genin protein
which is shown in green and this is
using an antibody to myosin Alexa 448 is
actually increasing and we can see the
number of green cells has increased at
day 5 compared to day 0 and also we can
see that the number of green cells with
myosin protein also have my genin mRNA
indicating that these cells are actively
differentiating the red in this image is
just beta-actin mRNA just used as a
housekeeping control in our study here
in this slide what we've done is we've
looked at Maya genin protein and mRNA in
the same group of cells and also with
beta-actin so the protein is Maya genin
and it's conjugated to elect before 48
and that's shown in green and you can
see the number of green cells in day
zero is a fairly low percentage and then
as we look at day three and day five we
see the number of cells that actually
Express the protein and the myojin and
mRNA which are the white dots is
actually increasing and we can even see
the start of the expression and the
formation of Maya tubules which is the
classic phenotypic thing that these
cells do as they start to differentiate
so this is shown when I show you a Maya
tube you'll hear so Maya tubules have
multiple nuclei spread along what
appears is a long continuous cytoplasm
where these cells have fused together to
these mono tubules and I think that this
really highlights the heterogeneity of
the culture so we see that not all the
cells are actively differentiating some
are still at this point dividing as we
saw in the previous slide and yet some
have under started this program for
differentiation so I think in thinking
about the way we use that cultured cells
and cells that we think are more
homogeneous we really need to understand
and accept that perhaps those cells are
not as homogeneous as what we think and
I think this is a really nice
illustration of that
so everything that we've looked at up to
this point for the assay excuse me has
really been looking at mRNA but we know
that mRNA are really a small proportion
of the total RNA that are present in a
cell so the majority of RNA in a cell
are actually non-coding and this has
become more and more important in the
last few years as we've seen the
emergence of the role of micro RNA and
of long non-coding RNA and so this was
an area that we were really interested
in the lab and we really wanted to put
this date to the test to see if we could
detect micro RNA we also did some work
looking at long non-coding RNA I'm not
going to present that today but we were
able to successfully use the assay to
also look at non-coding RNA so long
non-coding so as many of you know micro
RNA are very small there are
approximately 20 to 24 nucleotides in
length they don't code but they actually
end up regulating gene expression by
directing target mRNAs for degradation
or translational repression so all of
the micro RNA probes that we use are all
type 1 this is detected on the tris each
channel of the microscope or psy 3 and
it's
because there's a very nice
signal-to-noise ratio when we use this
floor for the probes hybridize to either
mature micro RNAs or the pre or pry
micro RNA sequences which are the
unprocessed forms of the micro RNA so if
we look at some of the different micro
rna's that we looked at we were really
interested in understanding the micro
RNAs that are involved in breast cancer
we were currently making some antibodies
looking at proteins that are important
in breast cancer and we wanted to pair
that with some of the work that we were
doing and we really wanted to understand
some of the micro RNAs that had been
identified as having a role in either
causing breast cancer or some role in
response to breast cancer therapies so
these were just a few of the micro rna's
that we looked at and we presented some
of this in a poster earlier this year at
the ACR meeting where we really looked
at a whole panel of micro RNAs and their
expression in different breast cancer
cells and this is just an example of
some of the data that we found so in
this case on the top row we looked at
ki-67 expression so this is really
looking at cycling cells and it
localizes to moogly haven't shown in
pink and then we looked at micro RNA 107
and this is shown as the signal in white
and these are the white punctate
thoughts that we see so the antibody in
the micro RNA is on the left and then in
the center we have our housekeeping gene
just used as a control and the merged
image on the right really showing the
three the ki-67 the beta actin in the
micro RNA 107 and then in the bottom row
of images what we have is detection of
let-7 micro RNA and we see micro this
micro RNA is actually expressed at
higher levels than mere 107 shown above
and these were just two of our initial
experiments to really see if we could
detect micro RNA using this protocol
that we were using for the assay in this
slide this is
data taken from the poster that was
presented at a CR in April this year and
this was really a look at a panel of
micro rna's in different cell lines the
top row of images shows an example of
just very steady state levels of a micro
RNA in this case micro RNA 145 and this
was similar to other micro RNAs that we
looked at like mir34a near 143 were the
levels in these different breast cancer
cell types were actually a very steady
state we didn't see anything remarkably
different between them so these are all
breast cancer cell lines the skb are
three bt four seven four mcf-7 and the
MDA and be 175 all fit into a category
that's more a luminal type so these
display a estrogen receptor signature
and they resemble luminal types of
tumors the MDA and B two three one cell
line is a more basal breast cancer line
which displays more of a brca1 signature
and resembles basal like tumors with
mesenchymal and stem cell
characteristics actually so the center
panel of the center row of images
actually is looking at expression of
anti survivin so survive in protein in
green and this has a very interesting
localization pattern so surviving is
actually an inhibitor of a photo psious
it inhibits caspase activation and it's
associated with tumor reoccurrence and
poor patient survival but the protein
itself actually localizes to the mitotic
spindle and the cleavage furrow which i
think you can see in some of these
images here for example here in these
two cells and we see that the micro RNA
that we looked at here marijuana
seven in white is actually
differentially expressed at higher
levels in the bt for 7/4 line and also
the MBA and be 175 line so these were
similar to results that we had seen in
the literature from Riaz at Al where
they had looked at array results so
expression array
studies looking at this micro RNA in
breast cancer and we were able to
confirm that study using this assay the
bottom row of images shows a look at
mirror 221 and this is shown in white as
well and an antibody to ki-67 which is
shown in pink and again this is using a
directly conjugated antibody in the
assay and we see higher expression in
will actually Louis pression in the bt
474 and the MDA M be 175 lines it's very
difficult to detect here it's actually
fewer than five copies per cell and then
so overall what we see as a whole is a
low expression in luminal cell types
which are the four cell lines on the
left and then on the right hand side the
MD a and B two three one we see a much
higher expression of more than twenty
copies per cell and this really
correlated well with the microarray and
real-time PCR data that we saw for a
mere 221 in the literature
so overall the results from this assay
are very consistent with the published
microarray and real-time PCR data as I
mentioned before we were developing some
antibodies specifically to look at
markers for breast cancer and one of the
things that we were working on was an
antibody to her - so her b2 is the mRNA
that codes for the her2 protein and as
many of you know her - is very important
in breast cancer therapy and
understanding her to status is very
important for developing a therapeutic
approach for any patient with breast
cancer so one of the things we did
in this study was we took breast cancer
cell lines that we knew had established
levels of her to in this case the FK b
r3 and the bt for seven four lines which
are both classified as like a to plus
her two line and then the mcf-7 line
which is her2 negative and we went ahead
and we looked for expression of Erb B to
mRNA her2 protein in the center row and
the merged image is shown in the bottom
so the Erb B to mRNA is shown in white
and we can see that there's very
consistent expression of the Erb B to
mRNA in the two cell lines that are
reported to express her to protein and
we do not see any expression in the
mcf-7 cell line it got a little more
interesting when we looked at her to
protein because what we found was that
even though
Irby to mRNA is expressed in virtually
all of the cells shown that we looked at
as the two cell lines what we saw was
her two protein was but it was a lot
more heterogeneous we saw expression
that localized to the membrane and the
cytoplasm and that was expected there's
a lot of times in these cancer lines
you'll see a miss localization of her2
protein expression and we saw a protein
expression you know throughout the cells
but then there were some cells that have
very little protein expression but had
quite a bit of mRNA expression which was
rather unexpected so when we looked at
the merge image on the bottom you can
see that there are some cells where
there is a message shown in white but
there's not as much her2 protein shown
in red and this case i think what we're
seeing here is really a difference in
the cells that are in the culture so
it's a representation of what is
normally occurring biologically and it
may be that the cells are turning over
the her2 protein more quickly or maybe
the furby two message is just starting
to come up and protein has not come up
yet or in this case it may also indicate
it may be a say dependent indicating
that the amount of amplification that we
get using a probe for herb b2 is about
eight thousand souls amplification so
it's a much more sensitive look versus
using a protein an antibody to a protein
in this case what we did was we used a
directly conjugated antibody so we're
not getting any amplification of that
process one antibody is binding to a
protein and so there's no amplification
of using a secondary antibody which
would bind perhaps multiple primary
antibodies so that may also contribute
to the results that we see here and as I
mentioned for the mcf-7 line which is
negative for her too we do not see any
expression of the message or protein we
did a similar look for progesterone
receptor where we had a cell line that
expressed progesterone receptor and one
two did not and we see that progesterone
receptor mRNA is expressed in the bTW
474 line and we see nice correlation
with expression of progesterone receptor
proteins shown in pink
localizing to the nucleus and it's a
nuclear receptor so this is exactly what
we would expect to see and in the MDA
and be 175 line we see that we do not
see any message or protein we also
looked at estrogen receptor alpha so in
this case we used two lines one that has
low expression of ER and one that has
higher expression of e are the mcf7 and
we can see estrogen receptor mRNA
present in all of the cells of the BG
474 but the levels are extremely low
less than 10 copies per cell and in the
mcf7 line it's much higher the MTF 7
line we're able to easily detect
estrogen receptor alpha protein and this
is using an amplification step so this
is using a purified antibody followed by
an anti Mouse IgG one secondary with its
floor for conjugative and we see nice
expression in the mcf7 line of the ER
alpha protein in pink interestingly in
the bTW for 74
we aren't seeing that expression of your
protein which may indicate that when the
levels of mRNA are this low we don't get
actual production of ER protein or it
may indicate that the antibody is simply
not sensitive enough to pick up and
amplify and show the signal of protein
that's there so when we looked at ask a
performance for RNA expression what we
found was in this case this is a photo
micrograph showing Erb B to signal and
whites these are the white dots gap th
type fors pink and this is just a
housekeeping gene and ki-67 in green
which marks dividing cells and then we
went ahead and we counted 15 cells per
well and this was running to placate in
a 96-well plate format and if we looked
at the corrected total cell fluorescence
so this is done by simply marking a
perimeter around the cells and
quantitating the amount of signal within
that perimeter and then taking an
adjacent area where there are no cells
and subtracting out any background
signal coming from the slide itself to
give us this ctcf the corrected total
cell fluorescence number we can see that
the average ctcf across wells is very
similar and the CV values that we
actually see it a variance is actually
coming from the heterogeneity of the
culture itself showing that the number
of copies of Irby 2 and gap th actually
varies from cell to cell so to really
make this kind of data more significant
one would need to analyze a lot of cells
to actually approach statistical
significance and it just is important to
point out because a lot of the models
that researchers use are cultured cells
and cell lines and this is a typical
cell line HeLa here where we see this
variation in the
of copies from cell-to-cell if we look
at ask a performance for protein
expression shown in green here this is
looking at alpha tubulin expression and
again doing a corrected total cell
fluorescence for alpha tubulin across
wells and we've counted multiple cells
we see that statistically there is not a
fiscal difference between the average
ctcf between wells and this is looking
at groups of cells so the assay is
actually you know performing quite well
across different wells when done in
replicate now I want to show you a
little bit of data from some of our
early access sites and this is really
exciting this is looking at expression
and infective 'ti and this is looking at
Zika virus actually so these are
Bureau's cells that have been infected
with Zika virus and stained for tubulin
and we can see in the top row of images
that these are uninfected cells and I
draw your attention to the image on the
top right where we're looking at Zika
virus expression and it should be in red
and there these cells are not infected
so there's no expression of Zika virus
in the bottom row of images these are
looking at bureau cells that has been
infected with Zika virus and I draw your
attention to the right-hand image on the
bottom where we see red punctate dots
and this is actually the zika virus and
the merged image is shown on the bottom
left showing tubulin expression which
really shows the structure of the cells
and the cytoplasm along with those the
detection of the Zika virus in red and
this data is courtesy of the Brass lab
Abraham brass at UMass Medical School
the next set of data is really looking
at a model for circulating tumor cells
so these were and this is data from rare
site this these RS KBRA 3 which is a
breast
aDNA carcinoma cells that are spiked
into mixed blood cell population
and in the top row of images what we see
on the left hand side is the merged
image and this is showing cytokeratin or
epithelial cell adhesion molecule
expression which really marks cancer
cells and we see that those cancer cells
are yellow on the surface and then the
image to the right about the RNA plus
daffy this is looking at expression of
gap th in green and herb b2 so mrna in
red so this is her to message in red and
see we see red and green dots expressed
here in these tumor cells and not
expressed in the neighboring cells which
are just stained with Daffy and so the
bottom row of images is simply another
view within the same experiment of cells
that also Express the cytokeratin and
the EPP cam on the surface as well as
the RNA and the Daffy which really show
these cells at cancer cells compared to
the other cells here in the culture so
this is a really look at a rare
population of cells within this mass of
blood cells in the sample the next set
of data I'm going to show you is from
suzanne hong deke and this is from her
work out looking at the associated rat
hippocampal neurons and glia and in this
case she was really interested in
looking at neurons that are dividing and
differentiating along an inter neuron
path versus a different type of neuron
and in inter neurons Express parvalbumin
mrna and that's shown in the cell in the
very center where she's used an antibody
to microtubule associated protein to
which is specific for neurons and that's
shown in red and then the parvalbumin
mrna is shown in blue and you see blue
come tape dots around that cytoplasm
shown here and then she's also used an
antibody to GS AP glial fibular acidic
protein which marks glial cells so this
is a mixed culture of glia and neurons
where she's used two different
antibodies and one RNA to really
highlight the type of neurons that are
differentiating in her culture in this
data this is the same model this is
looking at 13 days in culture and this
is cam kinase 2a which again is an inter
neuron marker shown in red and the
exciting thing about this culture is in
this experiment where she can really
look at the amount are the populations
of neurons that are differentiating in
this culture so in the bottom-left
corner I draw your attention to these
two cells here where there is expression
of red punctate dots which indicate that
this neuron is differentiating towards
an inter neuron phenotype and the cell
on the right of the arrow head where
there is blue there are blue cont eight
dots and this really indicates that that
is along a more general neural lineage
so we see the specific interneuron
forming as well as another neuron and
again in green on this image are
astrocytes are cells that Express the GS
a pea protein so this is really exciting
to be able to look at the
differentiation the different
populations of neurons and be able to
differentiate them simply by looking at
expression of this particular mRNA so
during the course of our validation
efforts of the assing we we did a lot of
work looking at different probes we've
used over forty seven mRNA more than
eighteen micro RNA to long non-coding
RNA and to viral RNA probes to really
look at the performance of the assay and
you can say that all of those probes
worked successfully we didn't have
any that didn't perform well we've
looked across multiple cell lines and I
think from the first slide that I showed
you at the beginning where we looked
across different cell types we've really
looked at a whole smattering of both
primary cells and cell lines to look at
performance of the assay as well as some
of the more rare subtypes of cells and
even cells like PBMC where we've
actually site us on the cells down on
slides for antibodies we've currently
looked at over 110 64 different clothes
of multiple formats by formats I mean
conjugated to different fluorophores and
we've looked at structural transcription
factors a whole host of different
specificities and localization within
the cell within the the antibodies that
prefer formaldehyde fixation
formalization we have an 88% success
rate in this assay
so overall the performance highlights of
the assay are you can use to RNA and one
protein or you can look at two protein
and one RNA or three RNAs you can see
single copy sensitivity it's single cell
resolution you can have probes designed
for any RNA target you can use purified
by later or floor for conjugated
antibodies any of them work within the
assay with just minimal changes to the
protocol itself we get robust results
and adherent or suspension cells across
multiple platforms so either a coverslip
496 both plates or chamber slides and
really it serves as a companion assay to
typical fish assays or immuno static
emissary assays for more information for
the assay you can look on our website or
contact our tech support at either the
number listed here or the email listed
below and online we have our user manual
for the assay and protocol a white paper
detailing the validation efforts of the
assay and then a brochure on the right
telling about some of the applications
that the acetate can be used for and
with that I will
and can take questions now thank you
thank you dr. Becker Catania for that
informative presentation it's time for
Q&A if you have a question you'd like to
ask dr. Becker Catania please do so now
just click on the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window type your question into the box
that appears on your screen and click on
the send button will answer as many
questions because we have time for today
let's get started
our first question is what is the
detection sensitivity of cellular
cellular RNA in terms of the length of
RNA an expression / copy number of RNA
currently we've used the assay to detect
RNA species that are as small as 20 to
24 nucleotides the example I showed in
the data was the micro RNA and we've
also detected many mRNA where there's a
region of about thousand nucleotides
which is used for designing multiple
probes among that region so we have a
lot of flexibility in the type of
species that of RNA that we're looking
at within the assay can we apply view RN
A+ to F ste sections for example of
cardiac cells right now the assay has
just been validated on cultured cells
that have been fixed onto a platform
either coverslips
or slides or we can use cultured cells
dissociated splenocytes have been used
PBMC that have been saito spun on two
sides
it hasn't been validated for performance
in formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded
tissue at this point is there any way to
adapt this so that analysis of stained
cells can be done by flow cytometry we
currently sell an assay for analysis
where the readout is flow cytometry and
this is called the prime flow assay and
it's a similar athlete to this except
that the readout is by flow cytometry
not microscopy alright we'll just pause
for a moment you have some more
questions for coming in and
let's give it another moment here you
know while we're waiting for questions I
would like to once again thank dr.
Becker Catania for her presentation do
you have any final comments Oh before
you do that another question for you
what is the cost to have a probe made
probes can be made they can I'll have to
get back to you on the cost actually
eight the next is what do you feel is
the best normalization control for
relative mRNA level assessment typically
we use a housekeeping gene we use
beta-actin GAAP th sometimes the levels
of beta actin can actually differ in
cells especially during the course of an
experiment we can see levels that
actually fluctuate so a lot of times
we'll just pick a relevant housekeeping
gene and use that we have a list of
housekeeping genes that have been
validated for different cell lines which
is available on our website okay and
again as we wait for additional
questions to come in I just want to let
our audience know that any questions we
do not have time for today will be
answered after the presentation so while
we're waiting for more questions to come
in I would like to as I said once again
thank dr. Becker Catania for her
presentation do you have any final
comments I just wanted to thank you for
the time today and I'll be happy to
answer questions and they can of course
be submitted we'll follow up with the
answers for those thank you wait well
thank you once again I would also like
to thank our sponsor Affymetrix for
making today's educational webcast
possible before I go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through May 17 2017 you'll receive an
email from lab roots letting you know in
this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us we hope
whew against food bye